how is Hana handling all of this all the
guys Oh fighting over her oh my god you
ready we're here we're here we are on
the set of the sequel we're gonna get
right into it where does this pick up
where our Lara Jean here it picks off
right where the first phone leaves off I
think it's like a bit of time has passed
but not much at all large in future
Kavinsky are in love and they're dating
but this time it's real right so it's a
real relationship my boyfriend he's
coming everything in the previous film
is just you know they're pretending
they're part of this contract it's like
a legal thing but in the sequel it's
they're actually together for the first
time so you take something that until
they're not though right well I'm not
sure I mean you know what the sequel
explores is just the fact that
relationships can get be a lot more
difficult you know especially once
you're in them for real not know these
things but large and Peter really have
to grow up and they have to they have to
look at those issues head-on and they
just want to protect each other though
these tensions are good there's that
quote the the road to hell is paved with
good intentions and absolutely that like
applies to this how did you know about
this Emily's the first one was so
massively successful do you feel
pressure with this one because of that
I'm not even thinking about what it will
be
you know the first one was an
independent Netflix wasn't involved and
when we were shooting it we were
shooting it because we liked the script
also I was an actor I needed a job but
like you know I mean it's both right but
it's we just showed up the set we
connected as humans all of the cast and
we had an amazing time making milk in
the movie and then Netflix ultimately
picked it up and and with their
distribution channel which is global
then it's it's like saturated users
globally it kind of became that
zeitgeist but I'm not really concerned
yeah we're all here is the same
positivity couple new friends who I am
Jonny impressed McLaren the addition of
Jordan Fisher John Ambrose how has that
been and how does his character shake
shake so quite a little bit I love
Jordan don't like Ambrose tell me oh you
told me you guys have like this bromance
going on I mean Jordan yeah absolutely
yeah absolutely well it's hard to not
have a bromance with with Jordan Fischer
right he's won he's immeasurably
talented and in multiple different like
X performs of expression singing dancing
acting of diligence you know he's a
diligent human being and he he dives
into subjects with his whole heart
whether it's acting singing dancing
philosophy conversation who cook you
like whatever you know he's just a
hundred percent into what he's doing and
president I love him so much so it's
hard I mean obviously from these words I
definitely have a bromance with George
yeah I'm gonna need that letter back I
need proof when someone actually liked
me in middle school everyone might do in
school I didn't really care about
everyone who is the dreamier
guy Peter or John Ambrose yo yo I I
think I think it's gonna be very tough
for anyone to have a definitive answer
on that but I actually know for sure
it's gonna be split down the middle
Jordan's he's doing so much for this for
this franchise for this this story for
the character I mean
oh my god but I feel like Peter Kavinsky
and the first one was this ultimate team
dream do you live up to that level of
dreaminess look Peters Peters probably I
figured this would be the place to give
you this
because this is where it all started it
appears you'd be Peter yeah but Ambrose
is Ambrose so so good luck it's gonna
get testy how is Lana handling all of
this all the guys Oh fighting over her I
like that you're laughing at that
question well because it is large right
right Condor enjoying it too a lot a lot
of like it's so if Jordan and I went
when it when when Michael director and
DP says cut we'll still being like
character a little bit yeah and like
fight over it if you like it's like it's
like quirky like smart thing is that
he's really good at so like he'll like
win and like get her and then she'll be
like to me he'll be like you know we're
all having a lot of fun with it
are you guys like bonding outside of
yeah it's working with friends yeah none
Jordan for eight years he told me about
turning the hair makeup room into a
nightclub situation mm-hmm getting it
yeah that's always a dance party man I
feel like your career is exploding
between this and you have he-man how are
you handling this immense amount of love
mm-hmm for you are you enjoying it I
don't know honestly I couldn't be more
grateful you know to the Netflix family
to age to awesomeness Overbrook just
everyone who was involved in the making
it's all the boys and
anything I've ever really worked on men
and I've been acting since I was eight
years old yeah
and so you know this is a well over a
decade and to have all this opportunity
in front of me it's just blessings you
know it's just literally blessings and I
wanna I want to do right by my own
person you know for what's being given
to me and I want to do right by the
people around me and the people who I
don't know that are on this planet me so
when it comes to you know how am i
taking this love like I'm trying to do
it with open arms you know I just want
to take responsibility and really
leverage what's happening for the
betterment of not just myself but people
around me and everyone else I love that
it sounds like there's a responsibility
that you feel yeah we're all we're all
you know living organisms on a planet
you know it's you have to take
responsibility at this point in time
like is becoming is becoming critical
and if you're not taking responsibility
then you're a part of the problem yeah
do you what is the biggest part hmm to
your life right now is there one yeah I
make sure I got friends everywhere I go
sure all the time right
oh yeah I'll be like I'll be walking
down the street so I'm like kid like
runs by me with everything like hey you
know what keeps running I have never met
this person in my life play a drive-by
hello you know I feel like it's kinda
it's kind of cool I feel badly I'll go
into a restaurant and like if they got a
bunch of tables but like someone
recognizes me I might be able to sit
down just like these little things that
like people do for you and it's a good
thing and it's also like a kind of weird
thing you know because you cuz you you
get away with a lot more things if
you're in a position I guess like people
know who you are you have any my fame or
influence or or success in your career
you know people can look at that and
like you can get away with things you
don't have to be a good person and
people will still smile and laugh at
your jokes and like tell you you're
awesome
and that's a scary thing but it sounds
like you're working on focused on being
a good person no matter what
man I just I'm just trying to make sure
that the mirror is is unfought I just
want to make sure I can see myself and
for who I am and the things I do yeah
yeah clearly speaking of the mirror I do
have to ask you about transforming for
he-man
what is that like what kind of work are
you putting into that you know it is
it's a lot of eating like what do you
eat you would think it's awesome but
it's like 6,000 calories a day the
average person's supposed to eat like
2,000 calories a day
hey sorry cuz it's great I'm not
complaining but like you know look if
I'm honest like I you know I eat so many
eggs it's like eleven eggs in the
morning just for breakfast
and like it's got me thinking like this
whole veganism thing you know and not
for like like veganism for mmm I mean
allergies one thing and you know that's
that's one category but lately the
humanitarian environmentalists
perspective on veganism like I feel I
feel obviously don't feel that bad cuz
I'm still doing it but like it makes you
think about the intake of human beings
sure you know the amount of chickens
that are dying and the ones the ones
that I'm eating and it's it's like it's
kind of messed up you know and I'm
eating a lot of salmon and I'm like
eating a lot of cows you know little
Dickey said it best in that in that
earth yeah video you know it's it's if
you actually click earth and then go to
the website you can get more information
on like renewable energy and like the
food you know just the biggest issues
that humanity is facing facing as a
species into the globe's facing and one
of them is the fact that like do we want
to cut down on red meat and never eat it
again of course not like we all like
cheeseburgers but like would we stop
eating it every single day and maybe
only have it once or twice a week yeah
probably you know it's like can we do
these things so I've been thinking about
that a lot because you're eating so much
cuz I'm eating so much moving that I am
like like the 1% of the issues you know
I'm saying right now
of eating too many livestock eating too
much livestock a lot of calories have
you talked to your look-alike Mark
Ruffalo about transforming into a
superhero
you still haven't spoken why are you
grinning so much cuz I'd love to but
like you do time like like I don't want
I don't want to be like all right we're
gonna arrange it like nah man I want to
walk into a restaurant or walk into
something and like see him and I'd be
like yo I thought we were gonna get him
to be your dad equal oh yeah that's not
happening it couldn't feel like a
surprise yeah I know we got to arrange
for you guys let's go back to the movie
so in the first one you were in a fake
relationship that turned real what are
three things like three rules to dating
for you honesty so definitely not lying
I mean I think honesty is like the
biggest thing yeah you know just you
open about like where you're at like if
you don't if you're not into monogamy
like talk to the person be like hey just
so you know like I'm really digging this
vibe but I'm not trying to be boyfriend
and girlfriend or be tied down like it's
just not where I'm at if you're cool
with that great if you're not like let's
be friends you know okay because then
nobody gets hurt right or if you're into
monogamy you know just like date see how
it goes gonna be like you always been
real like we should totally okay so
that's the number 1 2 & 3 thing is
honesty honesty honesty you know honesty
that's a very gonna go how much more
dramatic is this movie then first would
you say because of the whole John
Ambrose love triangles that
raishin I wouldn't say it's more
dramatic
I'd say there are more stakes though oh
you know because there's a drama there
were moments of like like vulnerability
in the first one and they are in this
one to the differences this character
we've lived with these characters for
longer so there's much more at stake
yeah there's a real relationship at
stake and it's cool there's definitely
as the stakes are higher how our fans
gonna feel when they watch this one do
you have a message to them to get them
through the rough patch no hold on for
dear life
grab the Kleenex yeah yeah okay and I am
being rapped but we are doing a wardrobe
segment so I have to ask you do you have
a favorite look that Peter Kavinsky
wears I'll really wear anything that
Peter would wear you do my personal life
No
so what's the biggest difference between
your style and she's pretty clean-cut
yeah yeah he's a pretty clean-cut fellow
you're not trying to steal anything
I look home as when I walk down the
street no you I do want to point out
really fast can we look at your socks we
tell the people with on your screen you
got you got you huh Shannon purser far
from stranger things just it's her body
you've got you've got painted chucks you
know you've got these weird fuzzy alpaca
bottoms they're not really not back up
on them they do look fuzzy you know this
is the hoodie from this is the high
school that they go to this is a dive
coat like I'm pretty so this is Noah
pretty much so I'm not trying to steal
anything
none of the sweaters in there I got a
little tour of all the know these
letters I don't mind the way they look I
just wouldn't ever wear all right and
last question three words to describe
the sequel oh that was - okay we're good
oh and 24 okay we can do for ya Oh
long
[Music]